الصين تعيد مشهد التوتر الى مضيق تايوان
وتعلن عن تدريبات عسكريه مكثفه لثلاثه
ايام هدفها السيطره على المجالين البحري
والجوي في تايوان بالاضافه الى الاعلام
تدريبات السيف الحادي المتحد تاتي بعد
لقاء جمع رئيسه تايوان ورئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي كبن مكارثي في الولايات المتحده
ردت عليه الصين باستعراض القوه
المناورات تمثل تحذيرا جديا للقوى
الانفصاليه التي تسعى لاستقلال تايوان
ومعها القوى الخارجيه خبراء عسكريون
ومحللون راوا ان تدريبات بكين قد تكون
مختلفه هذه المره اذا زادت الاستفزازات
فان الجيش الصيني سيكون مستعدا لتسويه
مساله تايوان بشكل نهائي
التدريبات اثارت ايضا مخاوف كثيرين فيما
حذر البعد من تداعياتها لاسباب بين ارسال
الصين سفنا حربيه وعشرات الطائرات
المقاتله الى مضيق تايوان نشر عدد كبير من
خفر السواحل للقيام بدوريات استثنائيه
قباله تايوان استخدام الذخيره الحيه في
اقرب نقطه من تايوان لكن هل ستجبر تدريبات
الصين تايوان على التراجع عن تحالفها مع
واشنطن الرئيسه تايوان اكدت على مواصله
العمل مع الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى
للدفاع عن الحريه والديمقراطيه فيما وصفت
التدريبات العسكريه بالنزعه التوسعيه
الاستبداديه للصين كما قالت انها ستهدد
الامن والاستقرار في اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
لكنها لن تخيف تعوان
تهديد الصين لتايوان دفع دولا كثيره الى
دعمها في مقدمتها الولايات المتحده التي
اكد مشرعوها على تقديم المال والسلاح
لتايوان وتدريب جيشها لحمايه البلاد من اي
تهديدات محتمله جاسم محسن العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات